we would now like to use Newton's second
law to relate impulse to change in
momentum so again let's look at our
setup we have an object M a velocity V
and let's say here the picture as t
initial and we have some initial
velocity and then a little bit later in
time we have a time T final the moment
the velocity has changed and that's
because throughout this time interval
we're applying an impulse we can call
this the I hat direction
now recall that our definition of
impulse it's a vector quantity it's
equal to the integral of the force now
when I write force of t i mean force as
a function of time and that's our dummy
variable t prime it's not Force Times
time but force as a function of time and
we're integrating from the initial to
the final time period now here's where
we use the second the version of
Newton's second law which is that force
causes the momentum of an object to
change so we can write this integral T
prime T initial T prime equals T final
of DP DT I'll just make a note that
we've now applied Newton's second law
and because we're using our dummy
variable DT Prime and you can see that
the two DT Prime's cancel and this just
becomes the integral from t initial T
prime to T final of DP and this is a
pure differential and so we end up with
impulse is the momentum at T final minus
the momentum at T initial
now recall this is a vector integral but
a vector integral is just three separate
integrals for each component so each
component of impulse satisfies this
equation for instance the X component of
impulse
is how the X component of momentum is
changing in time now generally when we
write a final momentum in our final
state minus the momentum during the
initial state we can call this the
change in momentum so down here we would
have changed in the X direction and so
in conclusion we now have a integral way
of casting Newton's second law we have
that impulse causes momentum to change
and so we can see that the SI units of
impulse are the same as the SI units of
momentum which we saw before was
kilogram meter inverse seconds